what are the resistors going to do  some of them are just going to go and  get vaccinated without question but are  there some folks that will actually quit  a job over a vaccine requirement are  they more likely to fake their  vaccination results will they are we  going to see lawsuits come forward  saying that this is a violation of  who knows what but just some kind of  legal attempt to resist this is going to  become a huge issue now the easiest  thing from the standpoint of just like  do I go and find a fake vaccine card do  I hire a lawyer and file a lawsuit or  whatever the case may be the easiest  thing continues to be just go and get  vaccinated it's even easier to actually  get vaccinated than to fake a vaccine  card it's legal as opposed to faking a  vaccine card and it provides you with  some protection particularly against  serious covid hospitalization or death  so it's much more useful than a fake  vaccine card